la rumeur de sa retraite courait depuis
quelques jours et ambre lille a confirmé
mardi sur les réseaux sociaux
le quart-arrière de 44,1 choisi
d'accrocher ses crampons après avoir
écrit une bonne partie du livre des
records de la nfl
j'ai toujours cru que le football est un
sport sans compromis at-il écrit dans
une enfilade de gazouillis si tu n'es
pas impliqué à 100% alors tu ne
connaîtra pas le succès et le succès
c'est ce que j'adore dans notre sport
j'ai de la difficulté à écrire ceci mais
voilà je ne suis plus capable de
m'impliquer totalement
se retire comme le quart arrière le plus
accompli de l'histoire de la nfl il a
fait sa renommée sous les ordres de bo
barry tchèque avec les patriots de la
nouvelle angleterre de 2000 à 2010 9
remportant au passage six titre du super
bowl
[Applaudissements]
en 2020 il a quitté cet été pour
rejoindre les parkings de thèmes à b
avec lesquels il a gagné son septième et
ultime super bowl à 43 ans on se
souviendra de temps brûlé comme l'un des
plus grands à jouer dans la nfl a
déclaré le commissaire rodrigo d'elle
par voie de communiqué c'est sûr que
sont si strictes ghannouchi c'est facile
il a la majorité des records comme
passeur il a gagné ses propos mais moi
ce que j'aime beaucoup dans sa carrière
c'est qu'il aurait gagné à début de
carrière en milieu derrière enfin
intérieure selon gilles
brudy n'a jamais été le plus fort ou le
plus rapide mais ce qui a fait son
succès c'est son intelligence sur le
terrain sont habilités à contrôler le
cours d'un match permet pas encore joué
cette saison de terminer au premier rang
on n'est pas complété les verges et
l'histoire de toucher c'est exceptionnel
du sort c'est vraiment un ascendant
alexis titre du super bowl et ses
innombrables le record braidy est promis
au temple de la renommée il devrait
faire son entrée dès sa première année
d'admissibilité en 2026 mais dans la
mémoire collective il fait déjà partie
des grands parmi les grands parfums
guillemette radio canada montréal